regardez ce que je viens de recevoir ces
salles assez le média kit de one flosse
alors ça c'est trop gros c'est la
première fois que j'ai un truc trop
ouvrir ça met un peu galère personne au
ps regardez l'âge et les deux nouveaux
smartphones chez le one + 9 pro 5 g g le
one + 9 5 g et vous avez vu ça la
regarde et la silla on n'est pas dans
l'espace je sais pas où on est
[Musique]
là on y est là là on y est one plus one
place series best shot et si j'ai un
petit tiroir
hu alors là ils vous ont mis le chargeur
sans fil qui va en 50 watts deux petites
coques ou awa ça va être la petite
relève d'invitation j'aime bien toujours
leur système de lettre d'invitation et
petits mots de pete
on a un petit kit de démarrage quelques
petites informations pour le das pas mal
aux caisses et c'est bien que ce soit
intégrée alors le smartphone en lui-même
ce que je vois tout de suite est ce que
j'aime beaucoup regarder ce parce que
vous allez vous en rendre compte
là vous voyez là on ne voit bien là on a
un vrai reflet et là je monte et ben là
je disparais ya côté brument fait larmes
voix et là je deviens bourru mais ce qui
fait qu'il ya un côté qui est assez
sympa ça c'est très original j'ai jamais
vue ailleurs quatre capteurs photos ici
on va se le détail des quelques instants
le micro la le bouton ici pour mettre
vibrations silencieux ou sonnerie le
bouton pour l'allumer pour éteindre le
bouton de volume qui est planqué de
l'autre côté
ici en dessous on va vendre son tiroir
de cartes sim son port usb c'est son
haut parleur le micro qui est planqué
juste ici sur le dessous des micros pour
la réduction de bruit vous avez votre
petit haut parleur passer beaucoup de
fils ici face à ses rivaux l'ont fait
devant déjà la prise en main ouais c'est
pas mal un bon il faut bien de protéger
de façon on voit qu'on a des bords
incurvés et bien évidemment votre petite
caméra qui est planqué ici à irin qu
qu'à l'intérieur on a un chargeur c'est
la barre charge 65 votre câble alors ça
c'est le modèle pro où ça c'est rigolo
comme couleur ça change par rapport à
l'autre il ya les méfaits en fait un peu
brumeux la voyez on passe à trois
capteurs mais j'aime bien le design
comme il est fait là c'est super sympa
les boutons sont les mêmes le pro tout
de suite il est un peu plus lourd en
poil plus petit 1
ça se tient pas grand chose vous
préférez lequel vous le modèle pro
houleux
le modèle normal le wall +9 là vous avez
un ventilateur qui permettrait
effectivement de dissiper la chaleur
lorsque vous allez recharger sans fil et
bien évidemment ce sont des smartphones
qu'il faut penser à venir protéger pour
sa bien évidemment j'ai les com de mon
partenaire rhino schild alors regardez
j'ai une coque spéciale pour lui là
c'est pour le modèle pro vais retrouver
soi un petit noir mat comme ça super
sympa très élégant soit un petit effet
carbone et vous venez vous prenez vous
mettez votre smartphone dedans ça vient
vous le protéger ce très sympa vous avez
également cette coque en carbone et vous
avez plein d'autres coque également ça
c'est pour le modèle pro que je viens
vous montrer mais sur le neuf vous en
avez également ça fonctionne ça vient
mais le protégé c'est très sympa pas
sympa alors chers inochi nous en avait
pour tous les goûts vous avez également
des coqs dans l'univers de hunter dans
l'univers de forte taille
on va avoir du fairy tail de
l'assassiner schleiss roule c'est dur à
prononcer mais c'est sympa kokinis
également dans l'univers du sport avec
les chicago bulls coque approuvé par la
nasa
si vous voulez voir le dos de votre
smartphone vous avez la crh garde vallée
du mode enix prévenir customiser cette
partie là pour avoir différentes
couleurs ça c'est très sympa et vous
avez également une partie à l'arrière
sans appel les backplate ce qui vous
permettra de venir customisée de votre
smartphone dans différents univers
league of legends et compagnie et bien
évidemment pour sa protégée de l'écran
d'un smartphone avec votre impact screen
protector qui va éviter que s'il vient
de prendre des chocs de risque et
l'endommager donc ça c'est plutôt sympa
bravo merci qui merci rhino chine
le partenariat entre one place et à ce
blog dc faut savoir qu'il est signé pour
3 ans vont pendant trois ans sur les
prochaines versions des smartphones
douane plus on va retrouver cette petite
griffe ici à seul bled ça c'est plutôt
intéressant parce qu'ici vous avez
vraiment spécialiste de l'image donc un
savoir faire qui ajoutés en plus du
savoir faire du one plus pour aller plus
loin au niveau de la photo vous le voyez
sur le modèle proposé pas moins de
quatre capteurs alors ces quatre
capteurs qu'est ce qu'ils sont et bien
vous avez en fait un capteur principal
ça va être votre grand temps que 148
mégapixels ces capteurs de sony s'y lit
et mixe 789 couvre f 1.8 stabilisation
optique et électronique vous avez
également one plus est partie du même
groupe que au pot dont ils mutualisent
pas mal de choses au niveau de la
recherche développement pour venir vous
proposer des meilleures solutions au
niveau des
appareil photo et pas mal de choses
qu'on retrouve chez haut pour qu'on va
retrouver ici chez one place vous avez
un ultra grand temps que c'est une
lentille freeform la lentille freeform
j'en ai parlé ya pas très longtemps du
côté de chez au pot avec son aux pauvres
files x3 pro l'idée c'est de les réduire
la distorsion duo capteurs ultra
grand-angle pour se retrouver quelque
chose de beaucoup plus naturel donc on
vient faire les modifications
directement sur la notice des
modifications physiques avant d'arriver
sur des modifications logicielles pour
cet ultra grand-angle d'un capteur de 5
mégapixels c'est le saunier 1766 tout
bref 1.2 et qui vous permet également
d'avoir de la macro jusqu'à 4 cm et vous
allez retrouver également un tel
objectif est l objectif avec le capteur
de 8 mégapixels couvre f 2.4 qui vous
permet d'avoir un zoom optique x 3,3 et
un zoom numérique jusqu'à x 30 ans tout
ça on se regarde si quelques jours dans
le test c'est moi le temps de finir de
les apprivoiser
et puis vous avez un capteur monochrome
de 2 mégapixels vous pouvez venir faire
de la vidéo en 8k jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde mais également en 4k jusqu'à 120
images par seconde donc ça c'est cool
la partie logicielle est également
retravaillé vous le voyez notamment ici
vous retrouver un mode professionnel
avec votre niveau vous appelleront le
tilt shift que vous y retrouver juste là
vous avez un petit histogramme sur le
haut gardez là c'est assez
impressionnant ça c'est la 4k 120 images
par seconde mais également de la haye
luis cas à 30 images par seconde
le moins de +9 qui a un peu moins loin
le capteur principal va changer lui
ultra-grand-angle c'est toujours en 48
mégapixels mais c'est la sonimex 689
contre 789 ici vous n'avez pas de
stabilisation optique là vous avez une
stabilisation optique vous avez une
stabilisation uniquement électronique
une ouvre à f 1.8 vous avez un ultra
grand angle ultra grand-angle par contre
c'est exactement le même
ici pas de télé objectifs mais vous
retrouver par contre votre capteur
monochrome de 2 mégapixels et puis la
caméra de celle fille à l'avant ça sera
exactement la même des différences
d'ailleurs trouvé entre les deux
notamment au niveau de l'écran alors je
vais vous montrer le plus bel écran ça
va être celui là c'est du one + 9 pro
écran qui est légèrement incurvé alors
légèrement parce que l'autre est un
écran qui est complètement plat on a
vraiment un peu plus d'immersion avec le
modèle prodware dit pour ce que vous en
pensez qu'elle vous préférez vous avez
dans tous les cas des écrans amoled des
écrans samsung
la grosse différence que vous avez sur
le procès que vous avez une technologie
ltp au qui vous permettra d'avoir
notamment un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz adaptatif ce qu'ils
appelleront ici un taux de
rafraîchissement en 120 hertz intel
jean parce que lorsque vous allez
regarder un film une série et bien vous
allez probablement être en 24 images par
seconde en 24 heures ce si vous avez
juste une photo qui vient s'afficher
vous serez encore plus bas et lorsque
vous allez venir scrollé naviguer vous y
avez jusqu'à 120 heures c'est de la même
manière pour des jeux dès lors que des
jeux vous permettront d'aller en 120
hertz tandis que de l'autre côté vous
n'avez pas d'adaptateur vous avez une
dalle amoled mais c'est pas du ltp où je
vais uniquement avoir dû 120 hertz
contre du sang vers intelligent de
l'autre côté
et puis autre différence également ici
vous va pouvoir avoir du quad hd plus
tandis que l'autre côté ben non je n'ai
pas voyager pas l'option vous avez un
écran hd r10 plus avec une luminosité
maximale jusqu'à 1300 dit ça c'est ce
que nous annonce le one plus'' on
regardera tout ça bien évidemment dans
quelques jours dans le test ce cuban
plaisent à venir mettre également en
avant c'est toute l'expérience pour le
gaming le gamespace ici pour venir
acheter des jeux dont je n'ai pas encore
fait mais je veux le faire dans quelques
temps pas mal de petites options
optimisé carte graphique optimisé le
processeur optimisé la mémoire améliorer
également le réseau alors tout ça risque
de devenir consommer forcément davantage
et jouer sur l'autonomie ce que les fans
de 6,6 et proposer une excellente
expérience pour le gaming on sait que le
gaming c'est qu'ils sont extrêmement
importants journée pour tous les
fabricants de smartphones et bien
évidemment quand on a un smartphone
comme celui-là on veut qu'ils viennent
d'acheter donc derrière et propose quand
même mieux que vous avez instinct dragon
888 vous avez une fois à 8 soit 12 giga
de ram c'est la lpddr2 5
c'est ce qu'on va retrouver le plus
rapide en tout cas aujourd'hui là dessus
on la technologie de stockage chez lui
et fès 3 points en soit 128 soit 256
dont extensible on a également la
technologie hyper touch permettra de
réduire la latence tactile vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo qu'ils ont fait
c'est ce qu'on a trouvé déjà un peu les
autres années c'est à dire que c'est un
grand classique en fait vous retrouvez
votre haut-parleurs ici si les haut
parleurs principal avec un son qui
sortent plus de ce côté là comme ça et
le deuxième repas alors c'est loupé leur
vous avez en face à caen vous n'êtes pas
exactement la même directivité du son
mais ça c'est une une formule que
beaucoup de créateurs de smartphones
utilisés que one peut s'utiliser déjà on
va plus de sons de ce côté là que de ce
côté là on a un léger déséquilibre
si vous voulez aller vraiment plus loin
au niveau de l'expérience multimédia
l'expérience gilbert pouvait venir à
péret un casque sans fil grâce au
bluetooth 5.2 vous avez pour codec apt-x
appétit xhd hell d'ac également là c est
que ce soit sur un modèle de sur lot
vous avez
et batterie de quatre mille cinq cent
mille lits en paire eur ce sont des
doubles batteries elles sont séparées en
deux pour avoir une basse tension et
pour éviter de venir l'endommager en
rechargeant rapidement parce que si vous
avez changé à 65 watts et 50 watts donc
l'idée c'est de mettre de la basse
tension pour ne pas les abîmer
ça vous parlez de la recharge est de un
à cent pour cent en 28 minutes
directement avec votre argent 65 watts
et grâce aux chargeurs 50 watts vous
leur charge et de 1 à 100 % en 43
minutes
autant dire que dans tous les cas ça va
vite et si vous n'avez pas pensé à leur
charge et bien voyez le matin vous
prenez vous le branchez vous chargez
votre parti donc ça c'est très rassurant
vous avez de la recharge d'un art c'est
5 watts et la grosse différence dire que
vous allez retrouver ici c'est que sur
votre poids de +9 pas le modèle
professionnel mais le neuf et bien vous
n'avez pas de recharge sans fil
laissez moi vous parler des tarifs sur
ce que les tarifs de ces papys parker
j'ai tout mis là dedans le web plus neuf
pros vous avez deux config 828 et 12 256
la version 828 coûte 919 euros tandis
que la version 12 256 coûte 999 euros
c'est un produit qui est disponible à
partir du 31 mars prochain tandis que le
one club 9 828 à 719 euros et est tandis
que la version 12 156 à 819 euros une
augmentation de 20 euros par rapport à
l'année d'avant
et lui il sera disponible un peu plus
tard à partir du 26 avril savez ya un
problème de d'approvisionnement en
composants et en main d'oeuvre en chine
tout ça à cause du coc vide donc ils
doivent différer les sorties donc le
premier à sortir c'est le modèle
professionnel
moi ce que j'aime bien tout de suite
c'est effectivement un smartphone qui a
moins de 200 grammes il fait 197 g
contre 193 g pour l'os par trouve assez
fin et un bel effort qui a été fait là
dessus j'aime bien ce design il ya
plusieurs couleurs vous allez pouvoir
retrouver également un modèle noir qui
existe a vous de me dire lequel vous
préférez entre entre ces deux
smartphones j'aime bien le l'intégration
au niveau de l'appareil photo je vois
que c'est vraiment une très très bonne
idée d'avoir fait comme ça le
partenariat avec un seul blade me plaît
bien j'ai hâte de voir le rendu final
pour voir si les photos sont à la
hauteur car que oui quand même ce serait
un petit peu ballot tous sens en garde
aussi quelques jours dans trust dont
vous invite à nous rejoindre si ce n'est
pas déjà capé bien évidemment me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
d'ici là j'en vois des gros coeur
gros bisous beaucoup d'amour on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler des smartphones la bijouterie pts
ciao